-Our next guest represents
New Jersey's 3rd district in
the House of Representatives
Please welcome to the show
Congressman Andy Kim.
Thanks for being here,
Congressman.
-Thanks, Seth,
for having me on your show
-So, this is a historic
and somber day.
And I want
to talk about that, as well.
But I also want to talk abou
the events of January 6th.
And I think a lot of peopl
became aware of you
because of these photos of you
sort of helping clean up
during the aftermath
of the riots
that happened
in the Capitol building.
What led you to sort of
make the decision to do this
-I remember I was walking
through the Capitol
for the very first time
after the siege had ended,
the insurrection had ended
and I got to the Rotunda.
And this is such
a beautiful room, Seth.
It's -- You know,
I think the Capitol building
is the most beautiful building
in the country,
and the Rotunda
is the center of --
the building is the center o
our democracy in many ways
And it was disgraced that day.
People had defiled the room,
the building.
You know, I saw trash and
garbage all over the place
I saw cigarette butts put ou
on statues in the Rotunda
and thrown on this ground.
It was --
It was really tough.
And so when you love something
and it's broken,
you want to fix it.
And I tried to do what I could
to be able
to just get it in better shape
I didn't want to see
the sun to rise the next morning
on a broken Congress,
so I picked up a trash bag
and just started
cleaning up the Capitol.
-When did you become aware
of the fact that this had become
sort of a viral phenomenon
these photos of you cleaning up?
-Yeah. You know, it was no
something I was expecting.
And I remember, the next
morning, my wife called me
And she said that she was
on a video confe--
a video meeting for her work
and one of her co-workers
sent it to her, this photo
that her aunt
sent to this co-worker.
So my wife called me,
told me about it.
She said that when she saw it,
she immediately was like,
"That's so Andy. That's exactl
what he would do."
And then she said
she just started to cry
because I think just --
it was a lot for her to proces
of what me and my colleagues
and others went through
and our country went through
that day.
And I think that the picture has
really -- it touched her heart
It touched
a lot of people's hearts.
Because I think it just
represents that kind of --
that decency,
that small act of kindness
and, you know,
that kind of service mind-se
that I think many people
are yearning for right now
-Did it ever strike you that
not just you, obviously,
but anyone who was cleaning up
was cleaning up a crime scene,
and that, to some degree,
moving evidence
that could be used?
As we know now there
are multiple investigation
opened by the FBI.
-That was actually
the first thought
that went through my mind.
And, in fact, there were som
officers there in the room
so I immediately went to them,
and I just said,
"Do you need this stuff?
Do you need anything here?
And, you know, they said no.
They said, "It's just here
It's gonna be cleaned up."
And so, you know,
I started cleaning it up.
There were water bottles,
personal clothing,
but there was some stuff.
I came across body armor.
There was literally body armor
there on the floor
in the Rotunda.
And I went to them
with this, I said,
"Is this yours,
or is this someone else's?
And they said,
"No, it must've been someone
in the insurrection."
So we went through that.
There was a serial number.
We found out
that this body armor
was actually just purchase
two weeks ago.
This was not something that yo
can just get over the counter.
It's tactical-grade, and it wa
just purchased two weeks ago
so someone purchased this
for the express purposes
of wearing it to January 6th
to the Capitol building.
That's really frightening
when you think about it.
-Obviously,
that day was terrifying.
I'm wondering how frightenin
it is now
to return to your workplace.
And obviously,
security has been beefed u
since the day
of the insurrection.
National Guard
has been called in.
I believe this is a photo
from either last night
or a couple nights ago.
This is you visiting the
National Guard from New Jersey
your home state,
and bringing them some coffee.
Was the coffee appreciated
And how are they feeling about
being brought
into the nation's Capitol?
-Yeah, yeah.
The coffee was appreciated
They set off a little bit
of a debate on whether or no
I should've brought
Wawa coffee from Jersey,
but it was appreciated.
But, look, what the Capito
looks like right now,
it's a fortress right now.
And I walked through the halls
of the Capitol, and it was -
I have to tell you, I've never
seen anything like it, Seth.
It was surreal was perhaps
the only word I can use.
I saw thousands
of servicemembers, uniformed
strewn out
all throughout the hallways.
I mean, we have right now
United States soldiers
and servicemembers,
you know, we have guardsme
quartered in our Capitol.
This is the first time
since the Civil War
since we've had
anything like this.
And, you know, it just shows you
just how unprecedented
of a situation this is.
What we also --
I got briefed on the threats
against the Capitol,
and they were real.
There are real and present
threats against us.
And I used to work in national
security in counterterrorism
and the kind of briefing I got
about the threats on the Capitol
were more akin to the briefing
I got when I was in Afghanistan.
So this is scary.
And, you know,
we have an inauguration
just in a couple days,
and I'm really worried about
what's about to happen next.
-You know, you talk about
unprecedented.
Obviously, we have now for
the first time in our history,
a president
who's been impeached twice
And, again,
there's so much going on.
And one, I think,
position that those
on the other side of the aisle
would say as a criticism is,
"How can you both impeach
one President
while also launching
with the Joe Biden presidency?
Do you think it's possible
for Congress
to do both at the same time?
-We have to do both
at the same time.
And this is something that
I've been very insistent on.
We have to make sure
we move forward,
but it's also
incredibly important
that we don't minimize
what happened on January 6th
What happened on January 6th
was literally an attack
from one branch of governmen
against another.
And I think that
that is something that reall
has to sink in for all of us
And if we were to just think
about this as,
"Oh, well, we can't push
this forward right now
in terms of accountability
on the President
because of the incoming
Biden administration.
He's got appointees that
he needs to get confirmed
and legislation
that we need to do,"
then we are just minimizin
what happened on January 6th
as if it was just
any other policy issue,
as if it was just, you know,
another vote on the docket
And it's not.
We need to make sure
that we treat this as the --
just the absolute disaster
that it was
and one of the most dark day
in our democracy.
And it cannot be normalize
or minimized,
and we'd be doing our countr
a disservice if we did.
-You know, it's sadly too easy
to forget about
the mounting death tolls
of COVID
as it's sort of pushed off
the front pages
by the events
that happened last week.
Some of your colleagues
were in a room, a closed room,
with Republican colleagues
who wouldn't wear masks.
We now have three Democratic
Congressmen --
Congresspeople -- excuse me --
who've tested positive
for COVID since that.
You know,
we have a lot of Republicans
calling for unity today
as their defense
for why we shouldn't impeach
the President.
What's it like knowing
that they won't even take
basic safety precautions
in a time like that?
In a time where, look, I think
Republican Congressmen --
Congresspeople had exactly
as much to be scared of
during that day,
and yet in a closed room,
they wouldn't put masks on
-Absolutely. I remember
I returned to the House floo
after the insurrection
had been quelled,
and I sat there
just right on the aisle --
on the other side of the aisle
from the Republican colleagues
And I was just thinking ther
at that moment, like,
"Is anything going to change
Perhaps are they
going to find the errors
of what they were saying?
Are they going to pivot here?"
And I was kind of
holding my breath.
You know, I was not necessaril
the most optimistic
that they were going to change
but I was hopeful
that something like this
would be a shock to the system
And I remember we opened back up
in Congress,
and it was the most
raw and emotional moment
in my government career, Seth,
just that moment
when we opened back up.
And I remember the Republicans
started speaking,
some of my colleagues,
and they just literally
picked up
the same piece of paper,
the same speech
that they were going to give
just hours before as if
this had never happened.
And that's
when my heart sunk again.
Just what is it gonna take
You know, what is it gonna tak
for us to move forward?
And what you said
about the coronavirus,
we lost a colleague.
We lost a young Republican
member of Congress
who died
because of the coronavirus
We had a moment of silence
for him on the House floor
And if my Republican colleague
truly believed
what they said about him
that day and honored him,
they would do so
by wearing a mask.
Again, these are just connected.
We are just seeing how
they are not changing their ways
after these massive change
and these massive shocks,
and it is so disturbing.
-I think it's very easy
for those of us
who mostly see you
and your colleagues on C-SPA
to forget
that you also have families,
you also have children.
I know you have
two young children,
I think pretty close
in age to mine.
I can only imagine what it was
like for them last week.
Were they aware
of what you went through?
Have they heard about it since
from other people?
-Yeah.
Thanks for asking about this
Yeah, I have a 3-year-old
and a 5-year-old, two boys
They're real tornados.
I've got dents in my drywall
because of the Matchbox cars
thrown around.
But it was really tough
coming back to them.
I remember, on Friday,
I was rushing home
to be able to see them.
And I had to, you know,
on I-95, pull over twice
on the side of the road
because I was just
so overwhelmed by emotion.
And I drove straight to go
pick them up from their daycare,
and my 5-year-old
came out first, Austin.
And he gave me a big hug, an
he said, "Dadda, are you okay?
with this really concerned voice
I hadn't heard him use before.
And he said, "Did someone tr
to destroy your office?"
is what he said.
I looked over at my wife,
who was there,
and she shrugged her shoulders
said that she hadn't
told them about it.
So I don't know
how he learned about it,
but it was, I could tell,
weighing on him.
I remember he was with me
when I learned about
how Officer Sicknick died,
and I started crying.
That was the first time
he ever saw me cry.
So, there's been a lot here.
And I've honestly
really struggled,
in terms of how
I talk to them about this.
I still haven't found
the perfect words.
I may never.
But, you know, what I told the
is that that kind of idea
of "Look for the helpers,"
what I learned from Mr. Rogers
and what they're learning
from Daniel the Tiger,
and hopefully
those are some comforting word
as they were for me
when I was a kid.
-I certainly hope so, too.
And I want
to make something clear.
If your kids ever don't clean up
after themselves,
I hope you show them this photo.
-Yeah, it's gonna
guilt-trip them.
-And let them know
if you could do this,
they can pick up
their Matchbox cars.
-I think I'll just post it -
You know, I'll post it
on the wall
next to the dining table
to make sure that
they clean up after dinner
-Thanks for making time
for us today.
I really appreciate it.
And I do wish health and safet
to everyone in Congress
in these coming weeks.
Thanks so much for your time
-Thank you, Seth.
Thank you.